listen everyone has an opinion about
this horrific russian invasion of
ukraine we're approaching the two-week
mark of fighting but despite all the
press conferences the tweets the
official statements the debates votes
and opinions there are still a lot of
very serious open questions about how
vladimir putin can keep his war machines
supplied and funded i mean the fight
can't go on indefinitely so what's
putin's plan here
question one here
first the level of engagement by the
russian air force has been surprisingly
minimal thank the lord by the way and
i'm not using his name in vain there
military analysts are puzzled by putin's
failure to view to use all of his air
assets to create his desired dystopian
hellscape on the ground in ukraine
why is that well i have an expert on
this coming up in a few minutes
second is putin being strategic here and
calculating with his ground forces also
if he's holding his ground forces back
in this convoy why is he bogged down did
they not prepare
does he really want to destroy another
question major cities like kharkiv and
kiev does he want to obliterate
ukraine's major cities and ports while
planning to occupy them later
kind of an asinine goal right
can he afford to rebuild them later the
answers to these questions are still
unknown but they have to be asking don't
be afraid to ask questions don't be
intimidated you're not a russian stooge
if you ask basic questions here ask the
questions we deserve answers too
another question here putin's massive
convoy headed towards kiev it's stalled
there's a lot of reporting on this and
russian forces are frustrated due to
weather conditions and reported supply
problems in just days columns of trucks
and troops they're running severely low
on gas and food how does that happen
that's kind of warfare 101 right if
you're going to invade another sovereign
country god forbid wouldn't it be wise
to make sure your troops at least had
enough supplies to get there first beans
and bullets folks beans and bullets if
you don't have those two things and you
haven't nailed down your logistics it's
probably not a good idea to invade a
foreign country
we'll have a guest coming up on that
soon too lastly forget the air force
concerns for a second and the lack of
supplies for his invading army if this
fight's going to drag on for a long time
long period of time which appears to be
the case thanks to the resilience of the
ukrainian people then how does putin
expect to keep funding this war the
value of the ruble's trash it's garbage
it's bottomed out it's on the brink of
collapse it even hit 100 to 1 in an
exchange rate with the us dollar at one
point
folks the sanctions and banking
regulations through swift may not bring
down putin for good
but they're certainly contributing to
his ongoing financial and economic woes
how's he going to fund this war and we
found out tonight by the way mastercard
visa paypal all pulling out
perhaps the most critical question
however we should be asking
is what will a desperate
isolated vladimir putin do
folks i just want to say again too
ask questions
we should be asking okay and then what
if we establish a no-fly zone and then
what happens there are consequences to
that
when we know the consequences we all as
american citizens and smart people can
process them and talk to our lawmakers
and make decisions
us being there and asking the questions
it doesn't make you some stooge of putin
to ask common sense questions like how
do we avoid a possible nuclear war
those are real questions with real
consequences and one more thing the
reason putin doesn't have to ask all the
time and then what is because some of
our lawmakers here keep advertising what
we're gonna do sometimes shutting your
mouth is a good thing no one ever got in
trouble for not saying anything you
don't have to advertise to the world
every single darn clandestine up we're
going to be involved in hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else